is 6 13 it is Thursday morning and this
morning help for those of you who may
need a handout maybe just a lift some
support or information the Goodwill of
Southern Nevada hosting its annual
holiday resource Fair it's at the
Boulevard Mall and that's where we find
Candace clogs this morning with
information on free food and some of the
services that will be available to folks
today Candace good morning
good morning YouTube good morning folks
okay I may be Candace class but I might
be here with the actual real Santa
Clauses of Christmas as you can see they
have a few items out here this is just a
small portion of the food that will be
provided today but they're also
providing resources really the Goodwill
said in Nevada does a lot for the
community and I'm joined by Goodwills
Morgan Waldron thank you so much for
joining us you guys provide Career
Services you not only provide that
obviously you're providing um affordable
clothing tell us about the services you
guys provide and what people can get
here yes when you shop and donate at
Goodwill you're helping us provide free
Career Training so career coaching
resume assistance and job search
assistance as well as like training
services so you can get trained for a
job in I.T at no cost to you or in the
healthcare industry just come to
Goodwill if you're looking for a career
and we can help you get on that pathway
awesome and they'll be here doing that
as well but besides that they'll be
legal assistance folks who need help
with parental assistance food stamp
everything so really tell is how this
can help somebody during the holiday it
really changed their lives yes the
holidays can be a hard time if you're
struggling family or even especially for
single mothers so come on down and get
the food get the resources we have
housing assistance child care assistance
Transportation assistance and as I
mentioned earlier Goodwill has career
search assistance so you can get a
better job so you can get to a
sustaining wage awesome Morgan thank you
so much for all you guys do for the
community it all kicks off today at
Boulevard Mall at 11 o'clock runs till
two o'clock he's got to bring your ID
very simple of course we've got you
covered with all details on our website
8newsnow.com for now live from the
Boulevard Mall I'm Candace Charles or
Candace Claus 8 News Now